oh babe review everyone welcome back to
the greatest show on the goddamn planet
the show we read what were you doing
here again review memes that's right
everyone leave your entry Z and I'm a
bit of a meme stirrer I like means what
can I say
I wasn't cool in high school but now I
know all the subculture
take that liberals meme review everyone
first meme that's right
don't spoil endgame please guys please
no spoilers of end game in the comments
please guys everyone is so dumb
okay dumb dumb if you want to stop
someone from doing something you can't
just go don't do that cuz that in
evidence believes there's gonna be
someone going what you need to do to
counter the endgame spoilers
it's just spread a bunch of likes okay
you need to just start spamming
everywhere all these random scenarios
that could happen in end game like
ant-man marries dr. Phil Elin must kill
Stannis start dropping these comments
everywhere and eventually people won't
know what the actual spoilers are
because they're spoilers everywhere okay
that's how you counter spoilers you
dummies
now we're there's of course already been
theories out there like famous and
ant-man and there's plenty of more to
come out of it look at this spoiler
that's a spoiler right there man in Hong
Kong repeatedly beated up outside cinema
for leaking Avengers endgame spoilers
Jesus Christ people take this seriously
now of course I never heard of this
website and I never seen any this photo
could be taken out of any context but
I'm gonna take it as fact this does put
a smile of my face she's wearing the
stones be stirred up selling it
Carolyn's gonna put the Infinity
Gauntlet and end Ana's ass I thought it
said she's gonna put her hand in Thanos
and see that's another theory that could
be definitely possible in Jesus Christ
this is literally me if I saw brie
Larson
the only Brie I like it's the one of my
sandwiches is that does that joke
translate to English that's right it's
brie cheese that's right it transmitted
I look forward in time I saw 14 million
in 605 futures why the trick would you
count there bro
dr. strange Mila girl what if we use
100% of the brain don't watch end game
it contains a lot of spoilers for an end
game damn I take back what I said that
everyone is a ball of dung geez
some people know
[Music]
[Applause]
now we're worried that's right
in-game spoilers Thanos and endgame
speaks
meemers write that down write that down
that's right I can't wait for all the
new Sanders memes again I never saw the
last Marvel movie I'm not planning to
see this one I just need to figure out
the plot through memes and it makes it
way more interesting okay that's the
real way to avoid spoilers and game
spoilers people who don't care about the
movie that's right wait other people
exist like that this such as me I
haven't watched age of Ultron jet just
please don't spoil act therapist
minecraft dr. field Thanos isn't real he
can't hurt you minecraft dr. Phil famous
my god who would have thought Mark
Zuckerberg accidentally reading endgame
spoilers while looking through people's
covers say oh damn that good old Mark
Zuckerberg
okay we need more memes it was beautiful
please that come back I killed a dragon
I trained a dragon I raised two dragon
whoa there buddy this could have been
the end game spoiler you need to be
careful yikes that was close mom can we
watch Avengers in game mom we have
Avengers at home I've been just in-game
at home Bible man see this is a movie I
want to see is that real Bible man power
source fiber Bible Bible man is real
Bible man defeating shadow of doubt
Eunice not stop your parents from
arguing but talking to God it kind of
looks like goose way misny I need to
watch this I will under on eclis watch
this all right end game spoiler gets a 2
I don't know what to tell you they're
just very popular because it's relevant
but I no one's gonna care next week but
there you go everyone next me
Pyrrhus the dog says yetis Pyrrhus
goddamnit Opie Opie pasty booth here why
is this a meme it makes me mad
[Music]
damn the editor
oh my god
Oh be mine
what the hell is this does it have any
context like um I've done cutest amigos
for casados a series for loyalty
asterisk oh man okay laser vieron el
tiempo necesario battle against a well
when we deal in Oh a loli Wow Spanish
memes are so good Wow 10 out of 10
that's all you need for memes do you
think just key Attucks no no go pee okay
actually plus yes
cute gear this why god damn it get this
no hey no no no creators of course
Gettis terrace wow he's so dreamy
thank you yes I really hit the fat blunt
god damn it I hate this meme it gets
zero I'm sorry I don't know what to tell
you makes me can you guess what the next
Mimi's we've already sort of spoiled it
that's right everyone mom can we stop at
McDonald's mom we have food at home food
at home it's a bit of an older meme but
it still needs to be reviewed goddammit
I've been on holiday what do you want
from me why is this a meme that just try
sends all language at all culture
everyone can understand this meme anyone
that grew up at the age of McDonald's
knows the feeling when they say we have
food at home and you know exactly what
that means it's not gonna be good
there's never ever been a time where
they say we have food at home and the
food the meal is actually better than
McDonald's
can we eat at home no there's food at
McDonald's yeah I guess that's the point
but you got happy meal at least then
come on can we please buy the new
Nintendo switch we already have consoles
at home consoles I'd hope you don't get
it mom mom am i beautiful like a prince
the Prince thanks mom mom can I get a
dolphin no we'd have a dolphin at home
dolphin at home is dead mom Jesus Christ
hey let's stop please
me at the store mom can I have minecraft
mom no we have games at home games in
fortnight basically when your mom passes
McDonald's and says there's food at home
it's funny because everyone can relate
to these everyone has been in that
moment and it hurts it really hurts and
I feel your pain smash you like on this
video if you feel pain right now can I
have sex no we already have sex at home
alabama'
feel like LM family you have a lot of
explaining to do alright there's a lot
of memes
trying to defame Alabama over here we
need Alabama to stand up for themselves
come on Alabama what do you got huh if
you're from Alabama I need to hear some
excuses right frickin now or else
Alabama is gonna be Alabama dama dama
you know what I mean me can we stop and
get food mom we have food at home food
ed oh hey that looks pretty good
I'll have a snack of that I have a
little
below that cooked banana with some
Cheerios and some mom can we get a
PewDiePie
we have Beauty Pinal Petey pine hope hey
I guess I was wrong there is a better
there is better snacks at home cuz yummy
yummy yum yum you know Jesus Christ mom
can we stop and McDonnells no we have
food at home my gosh mom can we have
some moto moto mom we have moto moto at
home moto moto at home well goddamn I
guess I was wrong again where there is a
better version at home god damn it me at
store mom can I have a Ricardo mom no we
have a Ricardo at home Ricardo at home
wait a minute this meme is literally the
Netflix adaptation mean that's right I
scooby-doo one wielded it it's the same
name basically mom can we have Marzia ma
no we have Margie at home
Marty at home that's right everyone this
mean yes I heard people have noticed you
know we always talk about the one mean
that will transcend all means that one
meme that will rule them all we don't
quite know what it is yet but we will
find it but there's been one meme
lurking in the background it's been
sneaking around causing destruction
making allusions making us think that it
isn't there when it's been there all
along
yes that's right I'm talking about
skyrim memes everyone the one mean that
just can't be killed
you expand toises can never be quenched
skyrim means it just can't die cuz old
memes will die eventually but skyrim
memes so far have not died for so long
so let's go through some of my favorite
Skyrim memes because they're funny
so I'm sitting on the sofa with my son
watching TV and he hears he got a text
on his phone that he left in the kitchen
so he goes to get his phone and it's
it's a text from me please bring the
chips and a Diet Pepsi on your way back
Ellucian hundred speech hundred
destruction
absolutely incredible McDonald's
employee fired for placing his mixtape
in children's Happy Meals merch hey
you've unlocked in your skill tree in
your opinion what's the height of
stupidity
Anakin how tall are you destructured 100
burglar on Oak Hill Community couple
discovered a thief in their home
Saturday after a man told a joke and
heard her laugh upstairs
snake Zira this is larious I played
elderscrolls blaze looked at the video
and Todd Howard is standing right behind
me I had no flippin idea sneak 100 town
Howard that sneaky son of a snake
I love these boy 10 sill parents car to
visit grandparents 68 miles away then
tells police he is a dwarf who has
forgotten his license snake hundreds
peach hundred illusion of 100 my god
some people just have maximized it all
nice earmuffs Potter did your mom make
them for you destruction 100 he doesn't
have a mom hitch mom it's dead hey wanna
flip if you want a floor buy one but if
you want a Kuenn earner how much for you
then oh wow
when Skyrim hundred tablets have lasted
longer than anything else and nobody
says anything
sneak 100 meme review ten babe it
mountain I'm sorry that's it for this
week's main review hope you guys had fun
and if you did clap your hands and I see
you guys next week
but tuber simulator it's now so relevant
that it's got a brand new mini game
cranium drop the crane and get fresh
items only available in the washing
machine like game and you say there's
more of course there is new knowledge
perks new quests and new pics links and
guys like